he held the pre e3 press conference in
LA live today so here's all the juicy
details on Mass Effect Andromeda
battlefield one and everything else I'm
added here confirmed that titanfall 2
will have a single player campaign while
the multiplayer is set to feature more
Titans who'll be equipped with extra
abilities the multiplayer trailer showed
off one Titan doing a ground pound and
another using a kind of beam cannon
against an opposing Mack pilots also
appeared to be getting the ability
upgrade treatments as they can now
teleport dispense gravity grenades and
utilize a new grappling hook in the
moment we've all been waiting for more
Mass Effect Andromeda info did arrive
but perhaps not as much as you might
have hoped a new trailer showed off a
sari and kirgan characters plenty of new
environments and a ship named tempest
are also featured was a female
protagonist waking up in a ship iWeb
said the game will give players more
freedom than any other Bioware game
before yay also gave us a tiny glimpse
of the truckload of Star Wars games
they're working on the publisher showed
up a handful of seconds from any
headaches game which is on its way from
visceral and gave mentions to the Star
Wars titles on their way from motive and
respawn among others while all those
games have been announced we did get a
look at some brand new things yay
announced EA originals a program where
they plan to partner with indie
developers to help create games sebastin
this program is an Orion the blind
forest looking game called fee fee is
arriving from Swedish developers oink
and appears to focus on a cub who wakes
up in the forest and ventures out to
discover more about the world around him
and his own origin in the scope of the
more familiar franchise fee for 17
showcased a new story mode called the
journey it'll focus on up-and-comer alex
hunter as he makes his way up the
English Premier League presumably
experiencing the highs and lows of
becoming a soccer superstar in addition
to that Premier League managers are in
the game
for the first time finally a closed out
their conference with another look at
battlefield a brand-new trailer showed
off ground warfare tanks engaging in
close quarters shooting aircraft
dogfighting and planes taking on a
hulking Zeppelin dive said destruction
was more intuitive than ever and added
that the in-game weather will be
unpredictable and require you to adjust
your tactics on the fly let us know in
that comment box what you cared about in
EAS conference and pop back to gamespot
for all the latest on Bethesda's press
conference later today